directors john anthony russo combined
arguably the most confusing element of
avengers endgame with one of the most
heart-wrenching moments in the last few
minutes of the film chris evans steve
rogers returned from his final
time-travel mission as an old man gifted
his shield to anthony mackie sam wilson
and kept coy about his wedding band that
we all know was a sign he got married to
Hayley Atwell 'he's Peggy Carter once
the fuzzy feelings at the scene inspired
faded though fans were left scratching
their heads and wondering how exactly
old man Cobb got back to the main
timeline as his apparent seemingly
contradicts the rules of time-travel as
previously outlined in the movie finally
more than three months after viewers
first watched endgame up on the big
screen we have the definitive answer the
Russo brothers recently held an ask me
anything session on reddit but a
detailed how the grizzled Captain
America found his way back to the main
timeline without completely shattering
the established time-travel theory the
ancient one stated early on in endgame a
fan asks the Russos how cap came back to
the present after returning the Infinity
stones to their respective places in the
past and requested some clarification on
the rules of time-travel according to
the ancient one when someone takes a
stone from its original place and
travels through time they create a
branch timeline that doesn't alter the
past when Steve Rogers returned the
stones following the big battle against
a nose he wore a quantum suits and used
a Pym particle to travel back in time
but when the oldest Eve appeared on the
park bench at the end of nth game he
wasn't in a quantum suit if cab figure
out a way to come back to the present
without using the same method that sent
him to the past that he'd live out his
life with Peggy in the main timeline
thus creating two separate Captain
America's and countering the rules of
time-travel altered he marry her in an
alternate timeline and keep everything
intact the Russos confirmed on reddit
that cap quote would have had to have
worn the quantum suit and he used a Pym
particle to rejoin the present timeline
just that he needed to do to jump back
to the past but the reason why he isn't
sporting the silvery suit on the bench
is because quite simply he took it off
earlier
according to the Russos quote that is
not the exact moment to which he
returned so there you have it cap did
indeed return to the main timeline using
the quantum suit and the Pym particle
but he was hanging around in the Year
2023 as a wrinkly white-haired old man
at least long enough to change out of
the suit and into something your
birdwatching grandfather would wear time
travel this explanation indicates that
Joanne Anthony Russo are of the opinion
that Stephen Peggy we United got married
and shared a full and happy life filled
with many evenings spent dancing in the
living room all in a timeline alternate
to the main
one of the Marvel Cinematic Universe Joe
Russo even told Entertainment Weekly in
May 2019
if cap were to go back into the past and
live there he would create a branched
reality however not everyone involved
with endgame agreed to that assessment
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely have maintained their
belief that Steve's grand plan to
finally spend his life with Peggy
happened in the main timeline meaning
that there are two Captain America's in
the MCU just after the release of
endgame Markus and McFeely sat down with
fandango's Eric Davis who asked if caps
ending means that quote an old Captain
America was hanging out this whole time
while another Captain America was saving
the day markers confirmed that he
personally rejects the idea that Steve
was ever in an alternate timeline saying
we are not experts on time-travel but
the ancient one specifically states that
when you take an infinity stone out of a
time line it creates a new time line so
Steve going back and just being there
would not create a new time line so I
reject this Steve is in an alternate
reality theory I do believe that there
is simply a period in world history from
about 48 to now where there are two
Steve Rogers and anyway for a large
chunk of that one of them is frozen in
ice so it's not like they'll be running
into each other it's hard to say whether
the two directors or the two writers are
more accurate here since this is all
science fiction but the Russos
explanation better aligned to the rules
of time-travel established in endgame
even so Markus and McFeely have said
that caps ending is open for
interpretation though here McFeely
preferred a theory to the Russos Marcus
has said that the issue of whether
Steve's life with Peggy happened in an
alternate reality or in the main MCU
timeline is quote a question with many
answers so mysteries sort of solved
we'll leave it at that check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]